history is often the greatest teacher by
looking at the past we can learn from it
with the benefit
of hindsight such as in the early 20th
century
when the entire planet was in the grip
of a horrifying war
at the time this conflict was often
referred to as the great war
although there was little great about it
others knew it as the war to end all
wars
the largest armed engagements the world
had known
although it would not be the last today
with that hindsight we just mentioned
we know it as world war one in june 1914
an archduke of austria was shot dead by
a serbian assassin
and as a result of the complicated
treaties forged between various nations
soon much of the world was involved in
the war that started out as little more
than a scuffle between neighbors
the horrors of trench warfare the
carnage caused by the earliest chemical
weapons and armored tanks
left a permanent and lasting scar on the
world's history
one still mourned and remembered to this
day
the advances in chemical and mechanized
warfare that took place during world war
one
range from the use of chemicals like
tear gas used to disable targets
to more lethal compounds like mustard
gas
and of course this was the first war to
introduce
tanks to the battlefield although these
were clumsy and cumbersome to begin with
it was arguably the advent of the first
world war that forced many advancements
in
armored warfare it was the belief of
many individuals on
all sides that if the great war was made
too gruesome
and horrific to continue it would come
to its natural end
this of course did not happen only
encouraging each participant of world
war one to continue advancing their
weaponry
but what if there were weapons developed
during world war one
that were too dangerous to be deployed
with every side looking for advantage
over their adversaries
what if some turned to the unethical
even the anomalous
to gain the upper hand in the war
introducing
scp-186 otherwise known as
to end all wars try to imagine weaponry
that was so incredibly advanced for the
mid-1910s yet so
horribly and unjustifiably cruel worse
than gas that can cause blisters to form
not only on the skin but also
inside the lungs more advanced than
armored vehicles with mounted machine
guns crawling across no man's land it's
hard to picture something that could be
more devastating than that
especially for the time period but a
good measure of a weapon's destructive
power is usually found in the damage it
leaves in its wake
in this case scp-186
is exactly that not the anomalous
weapons themselves
but the site of a battle that took place
between the 24th of july and the 13th of
august
in 1917. the event became known as the
battle of husseiton woods
but you won't find any mention of it in
the history books
any and all records of the battle have
been secretly expunged by the scp
foundation
and their own archive is now the only
place where someone can find the details
of what happened over those
few weeks the engagement took place
between the german imperial army
and forces belonging to russia's
provisional government
a small skirmish in comparison to the
enormity of many battles of the first
world war
so what happened at the battle of
hussein woods to make it so horrible
that it had to be stricken from the
historical record
for that we have to go back to heiseitan
a small settlement in western ukraine
in july of 1917 the surviving remnants
of a russian division had been scattered
the germans counter-attacked against the
karninsky offensive had driven the
russian troops to the dense forest
that surrounded the town of euseatin you
might be forgiven for thinking that the
outnumbered russian force was decimated
by almost
500 german soldiers pursuing them but
you would be
very very wrong as the opposing forces
met
they engaged each other in a fearsome
battle but this was
unlike any encounter that had taken
place over the course of world war one
or ever would again both sides were
armed with anomalous weapon rate
possessing technology beyond any that
had ever been seen
at the time to this day the scp
foundation has been baffled by these
weapons even with their unique
understanding of the anomalous
foundation researchers had been unable
to replicate any of them
and instead keeps them secured in the
munitions wing of site-23
all under the designation of scp-186-1
among the recovered instances of
scp-186-1
is a highly modified skoda m1909 machine
gun
however rather than behaving like a
standard firearm
this gun would cause rapid forming
growths not unlike
tumors to appear within the body of its
targets
another was concertina wire a form of
spiraled razor wire commonly used in
trenches
only this wire was coated in an unknown
compound that caused permanent
hallucination whenever the wire cut a
person
and allowed the hallucinogen to enter
their bloodstream
a number of rifle cartridges were also
found littered around
scp-186 sounds pretty normal for a first
world war battlefield right
except these cartridges were not filled
with gunpowder like you would expect
them to be
instead they inexplicably contained
human bone
ground into powder the purpose of this
ammunition or how it was manufactured
is still unknown to the scp foundation
as if a gun that causes tumors and
hallucination triggering wire weren't
bad enough
foundation researchers also found a
number of grenades used by the troops at
the site of scp-186
these were british empire standard issue
number 27 grenades
but they contained a unique anomalous
gas that was capable of passing through
any and all filters gas masks were
developed during world war one to
protect soldiers from mustard and tear
gas on the battlefield
but these masks only offered basic
filtration by today's standards
even so the gas contained in these
grenades was strong enough to negate
any and all filtration systems but that
was far from its worst
quality did this unknown gas choke
troops
not quite did it disable them like tear
gas
in a way yes but this gas did so by
making any soldier exposed to it
experience the sensation of having their
bodies set
on fire constantly also recovered at
scp-186 were the remains of some form of
explosive
and it is believed by the foundation
that it was detonated at the culmination
of the battle of hewson woods
causing approximately a third of the
battle's total casualties
foundation researchers estimate that
almost 300 civilians were either caught
in the blast
or died as a result of the crossfire
between the german and russian
forces the soldiers involved were also
all permanently incapacitated
or killed or at least almost
all of them so where did these anomalous
weapons come from
and why were they used just in this
battle not throughout the first world
war
according to records kept from the
public by the scp foundation
the german troops in the houston woods
were accompanied by a hungarian
advisor to their military named matthias
nemes
under his orders they specifically
targeted and tracked the russian
division that was retreating from them
who were similarly accompanying a french
scientist
dr jean taconde it was these two men
nemes and durant who were responsible
for arming the germans and russians with
their arsenals of anomalous weapons
they had ensured that their inventions
of death had only received limited
manufacturing
and had intentionally joined opposing
sides of the war effort to test their
creations in real combat
in other words it appears that dulhand
and nemes has been working together
since the beginning of the war
and the troops they were with had been
manipulated into taking part
in a big test these soldiers were just
as
unlucky as the civilians caught in the
crossfire
today the scp foundation has established
an automated security perimeter around
the site of scp-186
preventing access to anyone unless
authorized
everything within the perimeter is
frequently patrolled and observed by
security personnel
why the need for so much security at an
old battleground
given the damage caused by the use of so
many anomalous weapons
including those that the foundation was
unable to recover
the area of scp-186 has become a hot
spot for unusual happenings
even long after the battle of hueston
woods ended
these anomalies include abnormal
environmental or weather conditions
for example all the trees in the
southwestern portion of the former
battlefield died and decomposed at an
accelerated rate in 1923
while the temperature dropped to a
permanent minus 15 degrees celsius four
years later
but yet there was never any snowfall
then there were the sounds of gunfire in
1932
despite there being nobody inside the
scp-186 site
a number of years later a pair of
foundation agents disappeared on a
routine patrol of the area
and were never seen again of course 23
years after the end of the war to end
all wars
the world was plunged into chaos and
found itself at war once again
during this time scp foundation
personnel were instructed to evacuate
the site of scp-186
based on intelligence from their allied
operatives who were working undercover
inside the third reich as the foundation
disembarked their observation posts
a faint glow was visible coming from
scp-186
four years passed and the second world
war came to a close the foundation
returned to re-establish their
containment of scp-186
and immediately discovered 13 corpses
dressed in german army uniforms
bearing the insignia of the fourth
panzer army
there were further 27 bodies of soldiers
wearing the garb of the soviet 22nd army
both sets of bodies had already begun
decaying
although someone had removed the dog
tags and anything else that could
identify
these dead troops it seems that history
had to some extent
repeated itself as the nazi and soviet
forces had clashed on the same
battlefield where their german and
russian predecessors had fought
during the battle of houston woods years
later
in 1959 a large sinkhole formed in the
northeast portion of scp-186
four men were found wandering nearby all
extremely disoriented
wearing decomposing military uniforms
were they lost survivors of the nazi
soviet battle
no these men were in world war one
uniforms
german empire and russian standard issue
they had survived the battle of houston
woods and were somehow still standing
even though they should have died during
the first world war
how did these troops manage this well
the final
anomalous weapon recovered at the site
of scp-186 were mortar shells
but unsurprisingly these weren't your
standard high explosive artillery
much like those grenades mentioned
earlier these mortar shells contained a
unique
previously unseen gas but instead of
causing the perpetual pain of being on
fire
this gas altered the biology of animal
cells that it came into contact with
somehow it triggered a change that
prevented the body's cells from ceasing
life
function keeping them continuously
operational
in other words it meant that any
soldiers exposed to this gas
simply could not die that's right
some of the troops involved in the
battle of houston woods are still alive
to this day the scp foundation
immediately began
excavating the sinkhole and discovered
23 bodies buried beneath in a mass grave
there were more of the surviving world
war 1 soldiers
kept alive for decades by the mortar gas
some of them still had
infected wounds and battlefield injuries
that should have killed them
yet their bodies refused to die the
soldiers were rounded up and hauled off
to site-23
where the foundation researchers began
assessing them
however they were unable to glean any
useful information from the german and
russian troops that had been unearthed
all of the soldiers exhibited symptoms
of extensive psychological trauma
and had developed various mental
disorders while buried alive
under the battlefield they had all been
driven to insanity
perhaps as a result of their unnaturally
extended lifespans
maybe from being buried underground and
unable to die for so long
or perhaps it was the wartime atrocities
they witnessed that drove the soldiers
over the brink history is a great
teacher
but those willing to forget its mistakes
are often doomed to repeat them
matias nemes and dr jean duran created
the anomalous weapons responsible for
scp-186
and similar minds would later go on to
build the atomic bomb and countless
weapons of mass destruction
after world wars the suffering of
countless troops and civilians
these parts of history mean nothing if
we don't allow ourselves
to learn from them and maybe that's our
curse
as a species that we are doomed to fight
the war
to end all wars again and again
and again now check out scp-2270
major alexi belatrov and scp-1461 house
of the worm for more
wild war related scps